julian appling is with the wisconsin
family action office the place that was
just firebombed in madison sorry where a
fire broke out she joins us tonight a
fire broke out i'm sorry even uh to say
that to you it's got to be painful since
it was your office that was firebombed
what do you make of the coverage of this
by the way
well the coverage has been
amazing tucker and
um you know to see this thing go
national it's been quite a
quite an experience to be honest you
know we're an advocacy group an
educational group we do come at the
issues of the day from a christian
perspective
and i i to be honest with you i wasn't
sure what would happen after i found out
that we had had this you know molotov
cocktails thrown into our office fires
ignited
and you know graffiti written on on the
outside walls of our building so the
coverage has been mixed i've talked to
some media outlets where you know
basically they said that hey you guys
did this it's an inside job yeah right
we're going to destroy our own office uh
that's certainly patently false um
overall though i must tell you that
other than referring to us as an
anti-abortion group um which we would
prefer to be you know recognized for
being pro-life the coverage at least at
the local level and i think to some
degree at the national level has been
fairly even-handed
because we have such evidence i mean i'm
walking on glass in my office we have a
major cleanup job ahead of us in order
to get back to business as normal and
and tucker may i say you are exactly
right in your monologue this is
fundamentally because we hold a
christian worldview and actually live it
out when i work in the legislature with
legislators or when we talk to um in
churches or when we take our message to
the media that is the core issue
well yeah and it's a it's a pretty i
mean you know not every christian leader
um
you know fairly represents christianity
there are a lot of lousy christian
leaders out there but christian people
you know are are the are the kindest
people the most committed to human
rights of any group i can't think of
another more committed
why do you think they hate you so much
well you said it well
we stand in their way i have been at
this for 25 years and i've said it
repeatedly
when when there is an impediment in the
way of the liberal agenda they have to
find a way to sideline you to silence
you and i've even been told their
ultimate goal is to destroy us i'd say
they tried that on sunday morning you
know under the cloak of darkness when
they
attacked our office that was the goal
they want us to go away they want us to
be cowed into silence and i'm telling
you right now they pick the wrong group
if that's what they want because this
has made us stronger this has made us
bolder we're not going to go away we're
not going to be quiet we're speaking
truth we're helping people we're we're
encouraging people to stand up and show
up and speak up on these issues and
they've got to silence us in order to
keep us from getting in the way of their
agenda and their agenda is truly to
make christianity
exactly exactly
i think that's right julian appley i
appreciate coming on tonight and i'm
sorry about what happened
thank you tucker i appreciate that
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight